Germany's Defense Minister has put forth
a plan for the future of northern Syria
on a great Kevin Bauer's plan calls for
an internationally patrolled security
zone in Syria along the border with
Turkey that's similar to what Turkey
says it wants to achieve with its own
incursion there the difference is that
the zone proposed by the German Defense
Minister would be under international
and not Turkish control come Calvin
Bauer is seen as a possible successor to
Chancellor Merkel and she says she's
discussed her proposal with Mackel and
put it to Germany's Western allies
here's part of what the defense minister
had to say in an exclusive interview
with DW my first look is this via my
recommendation is that we establish an
internationally controlled security zone
in cooperation with Turkey and Russia
this securities urn would seek to resume
the fight against terror and against
Isis which currently has come to a
standstill
yes moment to thoughts might even become
is without off it would also ensure that
we stabilize the region so that
rebuilding civilian life is once again
possible so that those who have fled can
also return voluntarily well let's bring
in DWS chief political editor Michaela
Kutner who conducted that interview with
the German defence minister good to see
you mckay though so tell us more about
unag late what a neglect Colin Bauer is
hoping to achieve with this move well
she's clearly trying to change the game
at the power game that's currently going
on in northern Syria the Turkish
president add on is due to meet the
Russian President Putin today and
certainly they will be listening very
closely to what essentially is a
counterproposal to who will dominate and
who will control northern Syria it could
potentially be the European stepping up
to the brink no longer being on the
sidelines the big question is how
exactly this will look like in detail
and whether the other allies she's due
to meet at the end of this week at a
NATO defence ministers meeting will go
for this proposal and the
core issue of course is will turkey
eventually come round to wanting to be
on board now that it's so close to
Russia okay so would this
internationally administered Zaire and
that the German Defense Minister is
proposing would it involve both the
European Union and Russia because it's
hard to imagine Russian not being part
of that picture well I think camp can
Bauer says it would have to involve
everybody there's no way around Russia
in that region in Syria there can be no
solution without Russia also it would
have to involve the Turks but what does
involve mean I asked her quite clearly
whether this could potentially mean also
German troops on the ground a German
military involvement that here's what
she had to say the fogger the question
of how Germany handles this politically
and more than anything what that means
for our armed forces is a question that
must be decided by the Bundestag well
presumably the German Defense Minister
would not put forth such a proposal
without assuming herself that German
troops could be committed to that but is
it clear that the German parliament
would support that no absolutely not so
we pretty much I pretty much got the
standard German politicians answer it's
a it's a parliamentary army any kind of
move the German forces do outside of
Germany needs a clear mandate from
German Bundestag and a negated camp can
bars own party Angela Merkel's CDU is
currently in the so-called grand
coalition with the Social Democrats and
we already heard this morning a lot of
skeptical voices here this is a proposal
that has been put on the table without
consultation with the Social Democrats
in fact she sat with them the evening
before and clearly didn't mention this
so I think we're ahead for quite a
heated debate here in Germany yes she's
putting the pressure on her colleagues
there
so first Germany suspends weapons
exports to Turkey then Mackel tells
President erawan to halt his military
offensive in Syria now the German
Defense Minister is calling for an
internationally controlled security zone
in northeastern Syria
it sounds like Germany is becoming more
assertive with its foreign policy well
certainly Germany's defense
Minister and this is the interesting
aspect here looking ahead into what is
essentially no longer such a stable
government that is reassessing whether
it actually wants to stay in this
coalition just a couple of weeks from
now and clearly she wasn't just speaking
as a defense minister let's have a
listen what she said this is first of
all a proposal that I'm making as party
leader and as defense minister I know it
is a proposal that is supported by many
defense and foreign policy experts in my
party before going public with this
recommendation I informed the Chancellor
this will definitely be discussed within
the government but we can't simply talk
about Europe needing to be more than a
bystander we must come up with our own
proposals to catalyze discussion we must
come up with our own proposals and this
is quite a significant international
proposal and it's being put forth by the
German defence minister not by
Chancellor Merkel what do you make that
well first of all it's a paradigm shift
in how Germany perceives its own
security policy and it is much more
assertive than anything angular McCaw
has put forward in her time as
Chancellor in in terms of defence and
security in Europe and beyond so this
clearly is an attempt at an agreed calm
calm bar who many see as a potential
successor to angular Mackel an attempt
to step out of Michals shadow and it
will have a price to pay potentially
both within her own party and the
so-called grand coalition so she is
getting ready to prove to everybody both
her own party who's attacked her
recently but also the public where she's
suffering in the public opinion polls
that she can do German Chancellor as
well what about reaction to this
proposal Michaela have Germany's
European partners responded yet have we
heard from Russia I think we will hear
from Russia in during the course of the
day as Putin meets the Turkish president
a Duan from within the Social Democrats
and there's a very subdued kind of
reaction for now it would be very
interesting to see what the German
Foreign Minister has to say who
according to Anika Camp combo was in for
and through an SMS text message so would
be very interesting to see what quotes
we get there our chief political editor
Michaela Kutner thank you very much and
you can watch me cater this full
interview with the German Defense
Minister today are here on DW news at
10:45 UTC now Kurdish led forces are
leaving towns in northern Syria
apparently in line with the terms of a
deal struck between the US and Turkey as
part of anchors plans to establish and
control a so-called safe zone of its own
in the region as we were just discussing
there it's demanding that Kurdish forces
completely withdraw well the u.s. and
the Kurds once fought together in
northern Syria and now the Kurds feel a
deep sense of betrayal Kurdish residents
hurl abuse and potatoes at their
one-time allies they say they're being
left for dead traffic in the border town
of Qamishli was brought to a standstill
as US troops passed through heading to
Iraq leaving anger and betrayal in their
wake
all very small inside the coldest night
not embodied Okanagan ruined Oh
believable but nobody
it was a different reception over the
border armored vehicles bearing the
Stars and Stripes have begun arriving
there they'll be deployed to counter a
resurgence of the so-called Islamic
state but claims that the US have
abandoned the Kurds to a Turkish
offensive still persist you have to go
back to what our mission was our mission
was to work with by with and through the
SDF to defeat Isis we believe we
defeated the physical Caliphate of the
ISIS in March and but nowhere in there
was that we would fight a long-standing
NATO ally and in defense of the Kurds to
enable the establishment of an
autonomous Kurdish state no Kurdish
forces are on a race to get out of
northern Syria ahead of a ceasefire
deadline ambulances and vans were seen
leaving razza line a town encircled by
Turkish troops speaking in Istanbul
their president hinted at a continuation
of the offensive once the truce ends on
Tuesday night we have a trip to Sochi
Russia on Tuesday in this meeting we
will take up this process with mr. Putin
and after that God willing we will take
the necessary steps and further sayings
that Moscow is looking to fill the void
left by the u.s. Russian trucks filmed
in another two Syrian towns on Sunday
well short while ago I spoke to foreign
policy analyst Michael Fritz and I asked
him what we can expect from that
upcoming meeting in Sochi later today
between Turkish president red shift I
already want and the Russian President
Vladimir Putin we can expect really not
to be given too much overt information I
think that what's going to happen is the
the safe zone that erawan is so
insistent upon is going to come in some
form he's going to enlist Putin because
Putin is the Syria representative and
Syria of course has to be part of the
part of this mix all of the other
interesting ideas that are being put
forward for
instance the Russians Putin is talking
about humanitarian concerns and
stressing the fact that everyone has a
shaky record and anything that happens
has to be of the utmost with
humanitarian concerns and that's
something that's not usually associated
with Putin so there's a lot of new
territory to blaze here